des affiches de campagne qui inondent
les rues à niamey la capitale
ici les élections sont attendues avec
hâte et c'est dans un contexte
sécuritaire tendu avec des attaques
djihadistes récurrente que doit se tenir
ce dimanche le second tour de carolis
c'est ça les problèmes graves problèmes
de sécurité
à l'époque est détruit on a des voiles
du châtel qui fait pâlir agadez qu'on
applique go voyages chaque semaine trois
mois par la parole tout le monde
travaille tout le monde se soldait les
artisanes les audiences des voyages
grand favori mohamed bazoum bras droit
du président mahamadou issoufou est
arrivé en tête du premier tour avec 39 %
des voix un candidat qui ne laisse
présager que peu de changements dans la
politique du pays
ce que critique vivement son opposant
ancien président de la république du
niger et du en 1993 qui nous fait baver
qui prône la continuité mais les vins
n'ont pas de doha en vue de conclure à
gémir
le changement c'est pourtant ce que
cherche la majorité des nigériens ces
pirogues et payent un million cinq cent
mille francs cfa soit plus de 2000 euros
pour l'éducation de ses enfants qui ne
juge pas à la hauteur en matière de
santé et de pouvoir d'achat
même bilan que nos économies qui épouse
et tout le monde est malade sein
d'elecam un hôpital géré ça coûte cher
les produits ça coûte cher
non ça les troisièmes pour vivre pour
manger même un sac de mil
aujourd'hui ça fait au moins 23 me
toutefois le peuple nigérien et rassurer
le président mahamadou issoufou fait le
pari démocratique en laissant la main de
la présidence qui a donné un modèle
vraiment pour moi c'est un modèle de
donner cet exemple aux africains
de briguer des mandats et après les
scellés si mohamed bazoum semble avoir
une longueur d'avancé
l'expérience de l'ex président mahamane
ousmane à des postes clés du continent
africain président du parlement de la
cedeao ou du comité interparlementaire
sur les droits de l'homme de l'union
économique et monétaire ouest africaine
des postes qui pourrait peut-être lui
conférer une vision globale et
sécuritaire plus offensive que son
prédécesseur